what's your favorite interview question
when you're interviewing for somebody
for a job uh on a scale of one to ten
how lucky do you think you are
nice where'd you get that from when I
interviewed at Airbnb the founder asked
me it it's the Jeff Bezos question he
was the I think the originator of it or
made it popular at least they asked you
Basil's what's your favorite question he
said this and now a bunch of us have
stole this Joe Gebbia asked me it and I
told him a 9 or a 10 and he said why and
I explained to him why and I go why'd
you ask me that he goes people who say
they're really lucky are the people I
want to be around Raz like why do you
think that and he goes well if you're
lucky if you think you're lucky you must
be talented and things just fall in your
place or you actually are lucky and I
want to throw myself with lucky people I
want to be around unlucky people
yeah the specifically the question is
how like every person do you think you
are one to ten one two three is like I'm
not very lucky I don't consider myself a
lucky person four five six is I think
I'm pretty I think I'm you know decently
lucky average and I you know I think I
know why are sorry I don't know why just
that's just how it is and then this sort
of eight nine ten czar I consider myself
a very lucky person and here's why and
you want people who are either you know
if Lucky's a thing you want them around
you just like he said or if they're not
you want people who are optimistic and
you know when you're building a young
business you need optimistic people and
then the why part is interesting too
because some people know how to air and
engineer serendipity they know how to
engineer lucky situations for themselves
or they're looking out for situations
where they may be getting lucky and
pounce on those opportunities and that's
again somebody you want in hourly
business and then I'm gonna ask you the
same question and I think I know what
yours is but I'm gonna say another one
that is deadly I love this question and
this is when you back-channel on someone
and you want to ask about so let's say
I'm interviewing Henry and his old boss
no reference check I'll go I'll go Sean
what would you give Henry out of ten
just say number seven okay and you're
gonna give him a seven because you wanna
you don't want to completely [__] on
them and you won't but you also want to
be realistic and
I would then I would say okay well what
what can i what can he do to get the
remaining three points what could make
him of perfect ten that is the only way
I've ever devised to get ready to call
feedback on a person other than saying
what are they bad at well you know the
pretty good or that's that's what I
always say yeah for sure because people
like I said wanna be polite and then
people also don't want to like why it's
the best way I've ever found to get it
love it okay you're good reference trait
question for that specific thing yeah I
know what it is and you should tell it I
don't remember because I've told a story
once but I don't remember what it was is
this the founder of Second Life told me
once who you are who you want to be your
oh oh this one yeah this is a good one
yeah you know I love questions like this
I asked this in job interviews but I
also just ask this in social situations
to be awkward fill them I say hey we're
gonna play a little game I want you to
fill in the blank first thing that comes
to mind first answer best answer I'm
gonna say the first part you finish it
and I'll say life is all right less Alan
let's play all right sorry Henry you
have the mic so let's play first answer
best answer answer as you go life is
people are I am yes and then you use it
to sort of have a little bit of a
conversation you try not to judge people
too much off the top the mind but I
actually just think this is useful for
yourself so this is like your core
outlook it's like what's life and you
said life is great cool optimistic sort
of grateful person then you said people
are tough that's interesting why do you
say people are tough are you have a
girlfriend are you guys are you dealing
with some stuff right now you are what's
a situation where people have been tough
tough to deal with
people are tough to persuade or tough to
get on your on your page
that's a great question you totally have
you like you could see what he struggles
with in values yeah and then the last
one which is I am and you went with
Henry but a literal answer if you were
gonna do another one what would it be I
am okay and then the second question
I'll kind of ask is so I'm usually pause
there I do the psychoanalysis and then a
couple things happen people I uh okay
they just like want to leave because
they feel so uncomfortable or they'll be
like what are yours cool I like that
that's a good sign when you're asking
what are yours and then I'll tell them
mine and then they'll do the same thing
back to me and the last question is like
I tell him I said you know one thing I
did was I I did those answers top of
mind and I didn't really like what I
said and then I just reassessed it I was
like what do I think the answer should
be for me like what do I want my answers
to be what do I want my outlook of life
people and myself to be right what do I
want my mental model to be and then I
revised it and then the best people come
back a few days later and they're like
hey by the way I you know I came up with
my own and here's mine
and those are the people I'm like I'm
gonna be friends with you for a long
long time cuz you're like me you like to
do this stuff
[Music]